-Performing the title track
to their classic album,
"Stakes is High," once again,
De La Soul and The roots!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's go!
♪♪
-Cooler than cool,
suave then supreme.
Our cannibal tones
flow upstream.
We run lyrics,
lyrics that stay loyal.
And all lunatics
are the hip to our soil.
We are gods
and not goddess,
but we are gentle and modest.
We are here for you,
we are De La Soul with
the legendary Roots crew.
And we about to
give you a vibe.
Are y'all ready, y'all?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, y'all.
♪ You know the vibe ♪
♪ We want you all
to say vibrations ♪
♪ Stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them stakes is high ♪
♪ And when we say vibe
we want y'all to say ♪
-♪ Vibrations ♪
-♪ Come on,
stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them
♪ And when we say vibe, we want
y'all to say vibrations ♪
♪ Stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them stakes is high ♪
♪ The instamatic focal point ♪
♪ Bringing damage
to your boroughs ♪
♪ Be some brothers
from the East ♪
♪ With them beats
that be thorough ♪
♪ Got the solar gravitation,
and we're bound to pull it ♪
♪ We gets down like
brothers are found ♪
♪ Ducking from bullets ♪
♪ Gun control means using
both hands in my land ♪
♪ And it is all about
cautious livin' ♪
♪ Migrating to a higher form
of consequence ♪
-♪ Compliments ♪
-♪ Of strugglin',
shouldn't be notable ♪
♪ Every word said
be hip-hop quotable ♪
-♪ I'm sick of girls
shakin' asses ♪
♪ I'm sick of talkin'
about blunts ♪
♪ Sick of Versace glasses ♪
♪ Sick of slang,
sick of half-ass awards shows ♪
♪ Sick of name-brand clothes ♪
♪ And all these Jones
with their half-ass tracks ♪
♪ Cocaine and crack
brings sickness to blacks ♪
♪ Sick of swoll' head rappers
with their sicker-than raps ♪
♪ Clappers and gats makin' the
whole sick world collapse ♪
♪ The facts are gettin' sick
and even sicker perhaps ♪
♪ I stickabush to make a
bundle to escape this synapse ♪
-♪ See, life can get
all up in you ♪
♪ Baby, you betta organize ♪
♪ And let me tell you what
it's all about ♪
♪ Skin not considered equal ♪
♪ A meteor has more
right than my people ♪
♪ Wastin' time screaming
who they hated ♪
♪ And why them native tongues
are officially re-instated ♪
♪ The vibe ♪
♪ We want y'all to say ♪
-♪ Vibrations ♪
-♪ Come on ♪
♪ Stakes is high ♪
♪ Listen, why don't you
give it a try ♪
♪ When we say vibe ♪
♪ We want y'all to say ♪
-♪ Vibrations ♪
-Louder!
♪ Stakes is high ♪
Come on, we can do it,
we can do it!
♪ When we say vibe ♪
♪ We want y'all to say ♪
-♪ Vibrations ♪
-♪ Come on,
stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them
♪ Yo, it's about
loving of cars ♪
♪ Loving of funds,
loving to love mad sex ♪
♪ Loving to love guns ♪
♪ Love for opposites,
love for fame and wealth ♪
♪ And love for the fact
of no longer loving yourself ♪
♪ We living in them days
of the man-made ways ♪
♪ See, every aspect is vivid ♪
♪ These brothers
no longer talk ♪
♪ Hey, yo,
these brothers live it ♪
♪ 'Bout to give it
24/7 on the microphone ♪
♪ Plug one translating
the zone ♪
♪ And no offense
to a player but ♪
♪ We don't play ♪
♪ And if you take offense,
it gotta be that way ♪
♪ And my man Black Thought
got something to say ♪
-♪ I see G's are making
figures at a high regard ♪
♪ And people dying for it
nowadays ain't odd ♪
♪ Investing in fantasies
and not God ♪
♪ Well, welcome to reality ♪
♪ See, times is hard ♪
♪ People wanna snatch the credit
but can't claim the card ♪
♪ Showing out in videos,
saying they cold stars ♪
♪ See, things like that
will make your mama cry ♪
♪ Better watch the way
you spend it ♪
♪ 'Cause them stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them
stakes is high ♪
♪ When we talkin'
'bout the vibe ♪
♪ We want y'all to say ♪
-♪ Vibrations ♪
-♪ Come on,
stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them
-♪ I think that smiling
in public is against the law ♪
♪ Because love don't get you
through life no more ♪
♪ It's who you know
and how you, son ♪
♪ And how you gettin' in and
who the man holding heat, yo ♪
♪ And how was the skins ♪
-♪ And how high ♪
-♪ Yo, what up, huh,
what up, huh ♪
♪ I heard you caught a body ♪
♪ Seem like
every man and woman ♪
♪ Shares a life
with John Gotti ♪
-♪ But they ain't organized ♪
-♪ Mixing crimes
with life enzymes ♪
♪ Taking the big scout route,
poppin' out ♪
♪ Better than they know
they daughters and they sons ♪
-♪ And so people go through pain
and still don't gain ♪
♪ Positive contact ♪
♪ Just like my main man ♪
♪ Who got others filling up
his physical and fluids ♪
♪ His mind got congested ♪
♪ He got a nine and blew it ♪
♪ Neighborhoods are now hoods ♪
♪ 'Cause nobody's neighbors,
just animals ♪
♪ Surviving with that
animal behavior under I ♪
♪ Who be rocking
from dark to light sky ♪
♪ Experiments when needles
and skin connects ♪
♪ No matter if you don't
understand where we're from ♪
♪ They're called the projects
'cause when the stakes is high ♪
♪ They'll damn sure try to do ♪
♪ Anything to get
a piece of the pie ♪
♪ Electrify ♪
♪ Even die for the cash ♪
♪ But at last, we be out ♪
♪ Even though you wantin' more ♪
♪ This issue is closed
like an elevator door ♪
♪ But soon re-opened
once we get to the next floor ♪
♪ Come on, vibe ♪
♪ We want y'all to say ♪
-♪ Vibrations ♪
-♪ Come on,
stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them
♪ When we say vibe, we want
y'all to say vibrations ♪
Come on!
♪ Stakes is high, y'all ♪
♪ You know them stakes is high ♪
♪ When we say vibe,
we want y'all to say ♪
-♪ Vibrations ♪
-♪ Come on,
stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them
♪ 'Cause we are the vibe,
and we need y'all to know ♪
♪ Vibrations ♪
♪ Stakes is high ♪
♪ You know them stakes is high ♪
It's a moment in our lives
that is really important.
It's really important to us.
I mean, it guided us
in the direction that,
you know, it's made us
who we are today.
You know?
Fighting for our music.
Fighting for our legacy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, Dave!
-De La Soul!